I played recently in Gibraltar Open
tournament and six two games from God
tournaments to end games that I want to
show you today so you can see how to win
a game basically in a practical game
when you have a slightly better position
so in this particular position I'm
playing with the black pieces and
against a female international master
Cara body only for about twenty four
twenty feet a rated player she's a solid
player and she had beaten and draw many
genes so when I was preparing for her I
noticed that she has a pretty solid
opening repertoire and I was blocked so
I managed to get some interesting
position and here we are here and we
just exchanged it Queen exchange Queen
because as you can see I have a pretty
aggressive position here my bishop is
active my knight there's some potential
of the open F file to get open so she
exchanged the Queen's trying to
liquidate you know some pressure but the
first thing I want you to do I want you
to take a look at it for a minute or two
and so don't tell me what do you think
the evaluation of this position is it's
a slightly better is it much better just
to get an idea of like what's the
evaluation of this position is and then
we'll go we'll go from there
so you think why it is okay it's equal
black is better
maybe black is a big advantage just a
balanced you know I want you to get the
balance of this okay black is slightly
better
okay would tell me the reasons which due
to which factors what do you think is
that anything else here I mean if we
compare the pieces here if you look at
it right just try to compare every piece
individually you know let's start out
with a knight you know which Knight is
better placed
black night right it's very clear mine
Isis
only five on a strong outpost so that
gives me a class right there my bishop
is pretty active but it looks like he's
going to exchange it and my rooks are
better active you know the one is on
beat files putting pressure and one is
on F file so pieces are very active in
fact I thought I have a pretty
substantial advantage at this point
moment okay I thought it was a little
bit more than slightly better yeah
clearly black or white didn't you know
white is were sure it's so far away from
equality so she took I took and now she
play the correct move b3 the problem is
if she takes it will be just losing for
her because I just take on g3 you take
and now take after root B to go take b2
you have the second rank and this night
this this night cannot come in okay all
right so he played the move b3 okay
sorry she play the move between stopping
it now
I decided that I should try to open up
the F file so my rook is active right I
took and that way I forever take the F
pawn and there is no F form of here to
attack my knight so I took it he took it
and now my pawn is under attack the only
thing I have to worry about it here if
some point if if she manages to create
King g2 and if I might move my rope she
has Knight f3 trade in the night I'm
going to be in you know I'm not going to
have any advantage here so whatever you
do in this especially have to make sure
the nice remain on the board okay now I
have a couple of options to consider
of course d3 is a is a fine move as well
very appealing but I don't want to play
this yet so I could play d3 which is
probably a fine move but what else do
you can do here because looks like the
disaster playing b3 this look became a
little bit enacted here right
so what will be the correct move here to
try to make this look active again
what would be the move to make him more
active rook c5 correct and now yes I'm
also setting up a trap if he takes my
pawn I go rook to c2 activating my rook
and now threatening to play rook FF -
and our two dogs on the second run you
know that's going to be something really
strong and if you place the move rook F
form it's interesting I just take and
now Knight cannot take back because of
the beautiful fork here
winning the rook and if it takes for the
king you simply capture the rook and
you have a winning position so now Luke
c2 is a devastating threat so my
opponent play the correct move of D to
protecting the second rank now even
though this pawn is technically not
hanging but I don't want to have a loose
pawn always to worry about and plus when
you have a passed pawn what do you do
push it so I push my passed pawn and now
you know I have to look C to ideas
perhaps my opponent goes kingi - she is
trying to move the King away from the
potential chess on f3 so she can finally
start to move her Knight soon so yeah
the nice looks nice my rook on her face
I mean my piece is smooth they look good
but I still need to find a way to win
this somehow okay how can I try to win
this what's the next move that you have
to try to play you know it's very sushi
is going to run out of moves and sort of
it's going to be a loop the bank
position correct pinning the work it
takes I'm planning to take and now
threatening 93 move winning the broken
so I need to go fish
same thing attack takes the fork as well
see when you have a strong passed pawn
and a knight it always works out somehow
tactically for you so now opponent goes
here the rook edie one
and now I would really wanted to kind of
fix opponents a pawn structure so the
knife cannot move into the pawns cannot
advance so what will be that sticks
thing move here to make sure his pawns
are not going forward absolutely very
strong move h5 that also gives me an IG
force where in some point if the knife
of now she was not f1 she is trying to
perhaps move her knight only three
activate the night and then in a long
run come two three four just to give up
one or two pounds just to liquidate okay
just to simply liquidate my knight now
what can you do here excellent choice
yes nine three four now controlling and
stopping this knife from coming in so
basically this endgame is a domination
of one night versus another that's like
if you knew what a team that would be
the team the domination of one night
versus another
now she can't take because of the team
if she takes on c2 then I take with a
pawn it goes here then I simply activate
my rope to the Czech King has to go here
after loogie - it's a really bad
position because I'm threatening now to
play Knight here and 93 to win the rock
you can't really go anywhere okay
nineteen ninety five ninety three is
coming with some nice pressure so that's
why she didn't do that she went king g1
and now this is a chance for you to
activate your pieces a little bit more
what do you see here another move title
because you need to get in with your
pieces rook F - correct now we have two
looks on the second rank and if opponent
capture this pawn I was planning to go
check here and just come here and it's
very hard for him to do anything against
the triple fork you can lose one of his
rocks
so the best defense for her was probably
to take on f2 9 f2 would look b2 idea
but in that case I simply pick up the
pawn on e4 and she takes I go king f7
now all my pawns I'm protected next more
I will take this pawn I can also go
Knight f6 and you know this d5 pawn is
most likely to fall off so this is
technically winning position for black
she should have played for this this is
the best defense for her but she didn't
do that she went to she didn't want to
capture so she played a5 trying to make
sure she doesn't lose it now I want
another strong move here from you
without rushing she wants to push her
pants and maybe you know try to create a
passed pawn what would be the right idea
to prevent that from happening
a5 of course if I fixing it now I push
let us take fixing it again now before
trying to take yeah again yeah again
probably she should've went for that
lamb by this is already you know just
the desperation but position was already
difficult because again I was just going
to go to key 2 and then simply rookie 2
and here and here you know at the
problem here as actually she has no
moves like you know remember I mentioned
Azusa Wong this is a sucks 190 not move
this rook cannot move this route cannot
move except captures King cannot go away
look f-16 it's a real real loose one
that you know if she should try asking
h1 then you can see the tactic here yes
excellent perfect so she played before
we capture not replace a 5
now I realize I probably need to just
simplify the position so I took if she
takes with a knight who can show me the
winner
instantly you win this game there you go
there you go attacking that guy we need
to get perfect so to put the rook and
now 95 perfect the threat is to go
Knight f3 check so here my opponent
resigned because she really thought
there was absolutely no hope here so by
the way Kingi two losses to move 94 and
if take context and I'm quitting so if
Luke d1 I was planning to just simply
you know windows pawn Walker this this
way take now we go back here he tries to
protect his background check look at to
now the knight cannot move the King
cannot move none of the palms can move
the only thing is the rook can move so
now you push will see it and now we are
going to show me the tactic a strong
tactic to win
excellent 91 look at that or you can
really enjoy the position and just if
you really want to enjoy the position
you can mark your king here you know if
you do want to win slowly now I mean I
was probably just going to take on a fun
and go 91 but really it's a very nice
aesthetic position where the opponent
really cannot move anything except
moving the rook back and forth back and
forth okay well this was the game I was
happy to win a game against 24 100 with
a block th and move on to 2 out of 2 in
Gibraltar I had a good start and then I
start to play up a lot of my games after
this ok the next game I have for you
here Leslie that's the game against
another 20 2,400 almost 2400 opponent
it's a let's go through the opening so
it's a young player from Spain so I was
probably winning called better
throughout the whole game and but things
got a little bit complicated and I want
to you know get to the key moment here
so here I play the move Queen f5 and I
played this move with lots of confidence
thinking that this is just probably
going to be technically winning position
for me my opponent correctly took to can
we reach this position I have a strong
night on c5 and two palms and one of my
pawns is on a 4 so we both during the
game that this is probably technically
winning for me but here he had idea that
would give him a draw so I want to flip
this for a moment and give you a chance
to find the possible draw here that he
had it's very difficult to find it but
now since you know there is something
white if finds the right plan can make a
draw here
to my shock when the computer should
complete zeroes here I was like how
could this be zero so I thought I have a
clear plan and then when I see his idea
I realized yes this idea is very very
strong and I can't really do anything
about it no no it's not it's not it's
not a pawn move - it's not a break he
actually played g4 here I think I think
I think it's a g4 here but something
else it's something else you have here
okay my plan is this I just I just bring
the king to e6 and then I just going to
prepare b5 yes you know but then I
became comes three six very quickly yeah
94 I'll pick up the c4 on as well there
you're okay you're route 183 is very
well placed I don't want you to move
that rook because that rook is combining
block blocking the pawn and also it's
blocking the pawn and also attacking day
for pawn very strong maneuver then it's
suddenly very difficult for me to
untangle this position because I also
have my own weaknesses it's not it's not
a pawn break or anything I'm too strong
here in a center to to allow any for you
to be able to do any palm breaks
ah if you double the roofs let's say I
go here and then I'm going to go d5 and
I'll have to connect it past pumps and
if you sacrifice here yeah yo you might
have some chances but I think with the
amount of pawns on the board and this
passed on going down the line it's going
to be probably winning at this position
okay the first one is routed to now he
goes here and now you play a strange
move rook b2 it looks like we're
officially doing key e6 now d5 it's
going to be game over right getting the
two connected passed pawns now to b5
fantastic move now you're blocking all
the paths and now if I play b5 you take
pick look at that look a for winning a
very important pawn on a6 and the
strange thing about this position I
never plan I don't ever plan to improve
my position here I can't move my knife
because I lose a 4 I can move my rock
because I lose b6 and I don't have a way
to a template b5 which you already saw
why so if I move my king you just move
your king I go here let's say yeah I can
really move my pieces in this position
because you're also for example can play
g4 here in exchange everything and go
King g4 and King f5 this is another idea
so so this maneuver was very strong ok
rocky a little bit you but my opponent
played g4 this is time pressure so he
tossed upon it and to see if we can hold
i took he took I took on g4 I thought
probably I should be able to win this
now King G Street f5 now I have a very
strong protected passed pawn on f5 and
it seems like a very strong move now he
has to take the pawn and we made a time
control I have 4 pounds versus to a
passed pawn on f4 protected
one on g4 if I can somehow and this look
is actually pretty awkward here as well
so I played the move King f6 and I was
thinking this looks like it's going to
be a pretty nice you know win for me an
endgame
and now if he goes rook d5 I was
planning to play the part from Oh King
g5 followed by ninety four check pick up
the c4 and check moving the key to back
rank but now he plays rook e8 after a
long top and now I realize that maybe
it's not so clear originally I thought
I'm just winning here after 94 check but
I saw an idea for him here do you see
what's going to happen if I play 94
check finish what kind of resource
he has otherwise 94 check we just take
on c4 and it's just winning because you
could then you push the beep on as well
but he's got a very interesting resource
in this endgame correct 94 if I play he
takes I take and he takes on a 4 and now
my g4 pawn is hanging what to do so I go
here and now this to looks like I have
good winning chances here because now I
go to cap 6 look f3 and they should be
over but now here's another fantastic
move the only move actually he D he was
thinking about something else but what
he was he was thinking about this move
here but I pointed out to him up
thinking at this losses you know
possibly lose it because of this look at
3 check ahead so let's let's look at
this to make sure I'm right this is
losing ok this is losing check take
should be winning this so if you change
rooks goes here so we get this endgame
and I think I might be able to win this
because of this pawn here so here I push
push and I go here on ah looks like now
looks like here he's if he was here he
loses because I clean with the chick but
looks like now he achieves the draw by
playing this one push yeah he catches
the pawn at the very end with this okay
so looks like he's probably also drawing
in the King upon India because of that
particular move see for example this
loses this loses because I just I don't
have to worry about it because I just
just get a Queenie now I'll be one to
the check so and now just he has this
King III mode so yeah but the stronger
way to make a drawn here is c5 a
clearance sacrifice and now if I take it
takes this one now this is hanging
I'd say see for now check here's and now
what is the only move here to make a
draw for him because my Lukas excellent
big place behind a passed pawn and now
here's only one idea that he's going to
use to make a draw let's see if you can
find it t4 push I actually just push and
then I get into the magical magical
squad b3 then to win candy - it is your
sucks wonk
your sucks along here so see even this
position it seems like if you don't find
the right you're going to lose this
what's the only move you got it the only
move huh only move King f3 because now
he pushes g1 he pushes you go here
and now you're just going to go walk
walk and take the pawn so here take
everything got it
well what do I do I mean it was very it
would be very disappointing because I
think I had like much easier ways to win
this game and I really wanted to win
this game against him to move on to plus
three so I can start playing up here now
so this was like an opportunity for me
to to score because I would have three
and a half out of four and then I would
move up the next round so I didn't wanna
for to do so I dropped the rookin c7
okay
now I'm trying to go look to h7 perhaps
now it leads okay to he is suddenly
trying to get active we're really you
know we both spend a lot of time here
but now I know one thing and you should
know that - when you have a past pan you
look belongs where behind it
always remember that look belongs behind
the past pawn and now he took a chance
with this move but this will lose this
to a very beautiful and a long line okay
I push he checks I go here now he comes
in i push past palms meant to be pushed
remember that you have a passed pawn
don't think about anything else but push
it unless you see something concrete
okay
he checks I go here he checks
unfortunately this doesn't help me
anyway because this move because I go
check and if I go here actually get made
it 96 and just takes me so if I I can
just transfer to the same position so I
figure I just go here right away
if he keeps checking with this where
then my path is going to be much easier
I just go here I go here I go here not
this I hide
yes eh
if he goes look hga no perpetual no not
perpetual only go here he checks we go
here he checks look at that block all
right so he kind of got a better version
of what he can get here so he checked me
and now looks like he's in time he's
it's time to stop my pond from winning
but this is a winning position okay you
cannot afford to lose you're a to pond
so what's the move yes nice check now he
went down backwards let's take a look
what would happen if he comes here you
protect and now if he takes you push if
he goes here you step aside he goes here
check this way now his King has to step
away and now to past comps on the second
run they cannot be stopped with the rook
unless the rook is on the first row I
just check it's very important because
this way I move this King away so he can
no longer threaten the checkmate on me
and now I'm winning so I was happy to
see this because I felt like if I have
this I should have a victory another
trick that I had to calculate was this
movie for sometimes moves like this save
the game you know nice cannot take again
my a to pawn it's hanging if I played g3
he takes but now luckily I take this way
he takes absolutely important for you to
get the pawn on where e - e - yes now he
goes here your knight cannot move okay
your pulse cannot move and your king is
cut off but do you see the way you're
going to win this it's an amazing
position the palms and the night they're
protecting and you know the knight
cannot be taken either notify he takes
well nobody takes with an ID takes you
upon on a - it's not going to blunder
Drock there so the only way you're going
to win is now you move this way the King
okay so and you just go all the way here
so if it goes here this I'm going to
show you the similar line in the game
but this is the line just go all the way
here he's going to move and then you all
the way up here with this and if he does
this it's amazing that he cannot take
the knight because the e pawn Queens so
this doesn't have a way of the night
only c3 is protecting everything so so
he got another version of this actually
he was King G - I had to protect and now
he goes here he is threatening now to
walk with the king g1 and 22 now I have
to be quick here right king of faith I
gotta get out of the background okay now
you can see if he's trying to play the
move King - D - now I got here if it was
skinny - to attack my knight what is the
winning move g3 yes he takes the knight
you push and remember to past pounce on
the second round cannot be stopped with
a rook if it's on a 7 it has to be on
the first so that wins
so after g3 now he has to go back now
you continue with your walk you continue
with the walk and now he's like ok I'm
winning this guy you're attacking one
more time now I think what's here you're
going to get temple so here he can hear
me can't say yes to go here and now
continue b7 you move up King f4 you move
up
he takes here
you attack you attack because he has to
take because if he goes here now what
are we going to do
that's it
blocking the rook and getting a full
Queen okay so he has to take this which
I would take now he pushes the only
chance to march it we take you marches
it and now let's get a knight on d5 can
we his pawn is popped or a pawn is going
through and that's why he's resigned
okay it's an endgame that looked like
he's going to be able to hold yeah it's
like it looked so close to a draw but at
the end it ends with this you know
beautiful endgame there actually this is
actually winning
you know this position it looks like he
should you should be able somehow to get
a job but this this construction I have
with the pawn series is helping me to to
win this game
but again the critical line was also
this line you know king of for take and
here it's critical that I have this 94
check you know moving his King away and
then pushing my pawn without that is
going to be it would have been more
difficult all right okay very good so
let's do one or two study okay so I want
to make sure that you're looking at this
this this one in particular it's very
interesting this endgame okay you are
playing this position with the white
pieces and he has a passed pawn that is
ready to just push okay
so white to play and draw you need to
find a way to make a draw here okay
first two moves are very very important
okay
the problem we have here our akin is not
in the square okay so our King it's not
in the square here and that's why his
block is just going to try to push it
and we have to do something about that
well he's going to quit on h1 the black
pawn a fool he will just push you know
h5 a 5h or yes well the problem is bb6 I
go h5 your palm pushes are very forint
aha
it's actually the first move is very
important so King c7 is it's a natural
move but there are some things with a
campesino that you have to calculate
sometimes in these positions you don't
want to go to the most direct way
because of just the temples aha
King b7 correct he pushes correct
now you go King c7 it looks like why
would you see that you don't see the
point
now these three squares away from
queening he is three squares away from
Queens now what can you do here pay for
h3 a 5h to a6
h1 just protecting it so you got to see
an idea you guys need to have an idea
and you need to have an idea then you
will be good
we have okay I give you him we have done
a similar puzzle before okay it's
another one it's a little bit more
direct so I'm sure you will recognize
the idea when we do it at the end is how
you going to make that work that's the
key you know you know it's I know you're
calculating the pawn pushes and
everything but doesn't look like they're
going to go through you know they don't
look like it aha you have an idea you
got it you got to make it work too
you gotta make it work concretely yeah
so if everything else loses then we try
that idea right
so King up he pushes now you go here he
pushes
he pushes it looks like no way you get
us to mate this you have like a one two
three if you a lot of time we'll see how
you still made this b5 okay now he goes
here now attacks you what do you do
checkmate improve on that
a4 that's still mate okay if a four can
take it and if it goes now this way you
go this way
what if I go here I try to set up
another meeting idea if you push before
I go Queen 83 would it again absolutely
you play for perfect alright
last trick in this position what if I
played this move check I say take my
pawn
trying to us I see that you're trying to
do that self too much I'm trying to
sacrifice upon seeing a six when I'm
queen now then you have to take my pawns
it's not stupid
correct I push correct what we call that
now self still mate if the King wasn't
there he would go queen a8 and say
checkmate to you but it's there and
that's a box and that's called self
stalemate any questions
okay very good yeah we have done a
similar one before on a different on a
different side of the board okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]